[Musique]
bonsoir les offres au grand soir nous ne
faisons que passer car je crois que
nounours ne descend pas chez ses amis ce
soir monsieur patron messieurs je veux
je croyais que tu étais fâché avec je le
suis plus jr je leur ai envoyé un petit
champ à ma place mais ce soir chez moi
il m'attend bon le cheval
l'europe a pas eu de tels propos
[Musique]
alors comment se porte-t-il ce mineur
créé bien des morts cinq heures il a plu
presque tous sont les petits gourmands
tu viens dire bonjour a vu l'ours au
caire
ça y est ils roms c'est pas vraiment
heure où vas tu
veux te faire un billet
il me chatouille vaillant lance le faire
non sur matin d'une aux mineurs tu ne
manque pas de toupet elle est trop
mignonne sur monet maintenant non
noël halloween c'est l'heure pour les
petits chats 2 heures bordeaux
a dominé tu vas faire un gros dodo
d'achat ne faisons pas de bruit va
s'endormir
si on les châtaignes chassons c'est une
très bonne idée
moi c'est la fin de la journée
c'est la maman ne se couchait nous
faisons comme nos amis ils sont
doucement lee
nous y allons aussi
sur son nuage j'en suis certain le
marchand de sable vient
il nous dira
fermez vos yeux et domi tous les deux
nous sommes bien dans notre lit 90 nous
fait d'abord nuit sa grosse voix me fait
plaisir quand je vais m'endormir
non je vais m'endormir
safra nouvelle
plaisir
à présent que ce chaton dans vous allez
faire comme lui a nui nenê ce bonne nuit
les petits
la jette à lallaing
fait pour
[Musique]
alors ne nous ont rien à dire patron ils
sont parfaits même le petit chat s'est
endormi sagement j'espère que tous les
petits enfants vont faire comme eux mon
petit doigt me dit que quelques enfants
pas beaucoup ne vole pas le se couche à
ton petit doigt sa 39e oui ils se
trompent le garnement bonne nuit les
enfants fêtes de bourg eux
[Musique]